all right
caroline caroline where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
um i was born in el sarino east l.a
however i was raised in the coachella
valley like
india palm desert area tell me about
your childhood you had both your parents
when you were young both my parents were
dope pains
however i was blessed that my
grandparents took me in
at an early age and raised me as their
own
how would you describe your childhood
uh it was it could have been
oh it could have been worse um
i always miss my parents definitely but
like my grandparents definitely provided
and did what they could for me
how far did you go in school i
graduated high school um barely
um and i did some college out of college
though
where did you go after you're done with
school uh
i bounced around um kind of doing uh
like bartending jobs
restaurant jobs and anything or
alcohol was involved
is alcohol your uh it's one of my drugs
of choice not my main one but
definitely uh what are your main go-to's
uh
fentanyl heroin um
matt
what is your drugstore for you at
well i was like an athlete growing up my
parents my grandparents got me involved
in tennis
but like when i was 16 i was involved in
this car accident and uh
it was like one thing i was good at was
like taken from me
so like like that and
to handle it to cope with it i i started
you drinking and then like it led to
math per like really quickly like within
a couple months
i was using math on a daily basis
today you're using fentanyl yeah
where do you stay today uh
right now i'm currently residing on a
42nd street with uh
this uh this man i met on the streets
um he
kind of gives me a place to stay and
supports my drug habit
in exchange for uh
companionship uh sexual favors
um you were homeless before that
yeah i was almost um in pasadena area in
azusa area
and then even downtown i stayed at
the midnight mission for a while for a
couple of months but
i've been homeless out here as well
and how do you support yourself now um
as of now like my i rely on him
to support my drug habit like
before before you met him how would you
support yourself uh
abused still from stores people
whatever you know i could take for value
and sell it or trade it
or um to get some fast cash i would do
it
um um that yeah that was mainly my way
of like coming out
do you still have contact with your
family
my grandparents still around my grandma
she's 89 years old and
yeah she's still hanging in there and
she's actually i have a 14 year old son
that uh she's raising right now
and uh like
i've attempted like i guess four times
to
try to kick on i i failed and um
like i'm just scared that like
like a minute it's going to take my life
you know
is that your biggest fear is it i'm
going to die and my sons and i have to
grow up you know without me and like i
know he's already been
a few years without me but like just me
not being here at all for him it just
terrifies me
what do you uh what do you see for your
future i mean if you
do you see any way of trying to break
free of
addiction right now i'm just i'm feeling
kind of hopeless
um because like this
if you like ben has such a grip on me
it's unlike any other drug i ever tried
it's um
like the feeling it gives me and like
the feeling when i get it when i don't
have it
it's it's nothing like a
like a heroin kick or a methadone kick
it's
it's nothing like i ever kicked before
and
it's terrifying yeah i've heard it
described
by fentanyl addicts that it's like you'd
rather die then
then try to kick it yeah
like i attempted four times this year
and i failed
every time
you talk to your son still yeah i do i
call him
on a daily basis um
the relationship is as you can imagine
is uh
it's kind of strange he doesn't call me
mom anymore he calls me by my first name
which is uh it's hurtful you know
but um but i do have communication with
him on a daily basis
and like all he wants is since he told
me all he wants is
mom back and uh
i wish i could uh more than anything i
wish i could uh
do that for him
and i'm sure that brings up feelings of
shame and guilt for you and
things like that yeah yeah definitely
you know just
i'm sure you'd love to be there for him
more than anything you know
and like just supposed to be there for
him and my grandma you know my grandma's
uh
she's older you know and now like i
don't know how much time she has left
and like
i just want to be able to be there for
her
for her last time on here on this earth
you know
yeah do you feel like your addiction
might be
inherited from your parents i mean i
think it might be like i said uh
both my parents were dope things um
i really didn't have a much
communication with my mom growing up
like i only like seen her a handful of
times
uh my dad uh we were more closer growing
up
but like when i was 19
i seen him he was shot and killed by the
palm
springs police department and
uh two i really think that was like a
turning point for me
like you you saw that yeah it went and
said
you watched your dad get killed
all right
is this the lowest point of your life
right now definitely
like even though i have like a roofer in
my head right now
like the situation is so
demeanor like i'm
i'm not a straight woman you know i i'm
like
i identify as a gay woman i like females
i like to be with females and
like to be in
to have to do things with his mouth it's
uh
it's really uh so i feel like just to
survive you know just to
to have a place to lay my head at night
you know it's
um
it's definitely difficult
do you have friends
yeah yeah just acquaintances on the
street yeah
[Music]
do you have hope of getting your life on
track
with fentanyl addiction it's it's tough
to imagine
breaking free of that but
my hope is very small right now it's
very limited
and um
with all the fentanyl deaths recently
it's got to be scary right
my tolerance is so high it's
um i highly
um i don't you think you think you're
immune to that now
i just my taunt is like super high you
know like i
sometimes i don't eat like i don't even
get high anymore i just get well
and like for fentanyl like that's
that's pretty uh
pretty bad a habit you know
like my habits anywhere from two to
three hundred dollars a day
oh really any guy you're staying with
pays for that
he's got you where he wants you
back to your childhood you was there
anything about your childhood that
led you down this path you feel or do
you think it was all just
the parents that you had
i mean i just think the absence of my
parents not being there
and like um
like having the one thing i was i felt
like i was
good at like taking for me like
i mean after that car accident and after
uh i wasn't able to play tennis anymore
like
i was like whoa what's the point
what's the point of like
so like after that like it was really um
a turning point
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
friends are hard to come by you know
it's hard to
trust people especially on the streets
[Music]
but if you could find that one friend
that one person that has your back
that one person that like won't steal
from you won't be dirty
it's rare and like hold on to it you
know and like
and appreciate it and like
reciprocate it you know do the same
treat them the same yeah
i haven't found that by the way
all right caroline well thank you so
much for sharing your story
okay we wish you the best of luck with
your
with your addiction
you